tu dois passer à la deuxième étape de
ton parcours
un jour qui disposera d'un pouvoir
incroyable
la justice est un plat qui se mange
chaud on va prendre deux plateaux
justice s'il te plaît tu y restes tu
vaux de la sauce avec à part la sauce
pour tigre et sa part la sauce à part la
source
si tu te contentes de faire ce que tu es
capable de faire que ne progressera pas
et tu resteras tels que tuer lui-même
bien comme je suis petit ne sais même
pas qui tu es
je suis à la recherche de mon fils
embrasse ton vieux port de pêche mais
qu'est ce qui nous prouve que vous êtes
son père et sa là c'est quoi
on a l'impression de se voir dans un
miroir grossissant entre avec moi au
bénin il faut que tu re découvre ce que
c'est que d'être un panda oui je vais le
cet abîme qui ça le maître du mal la
belle comtesse le faiseur de veuves
connaît d'accord je travaillais avec au
bout et il faut que tu sauves le monde
voudrait jamais l'arrêter
sauf si tu as ta propre armée vous ne
connaissez pas le kung fu mais tu peux
nous l'enseigné
personne n'a dit que ce serait facile je
vais faire de vous des maîtres du kung
fu la brigade des raviolis se
positionnera ici est un bon signal
la brigade des nourrices et c'est
exactement la nec
j'aurais dû m'en douter c'est ça me
sauveur destiné à me battre tu en viens
vous faites de jackass et je vais m'en
paraître de jacasser devant castres
jacques as tu vas y toi que tu jacques à
tujac as coteaux unique s works
présentent kung fu panda 3 sas et
l'armure de mettre rhino volant quoi ça
sert ce truc je vais tirer dessus
je crois que je me suis fait taper
dessus